بشأن مقتل الصحفي جمال
كيشافجي ، يريد الكثير من الناس معرفة
ما ستفعله الولايات المتحدة ، وبما أنني
أجلس معك ما الذي ستفعله
كندا ، فقد أبرمت كندا صفقة بقيمة خمسة عشر مليار دولار
لبيع مركبات مدرعة خفيفة إلى المملكة
العربية السعودية التي قلتها الشهر الماضي
يتوقع الكنديون أن تكون هناك عواقب
لقتل جمال كوش أوكتري مع سبق الإصرار ،
فهل تلغي كندا مبيعات الأسلحة التي
كنا نعمل معها مع المجتمع الدولي
لمحاولة الحصول على إجابات بشأن
جريمة القتل الرهيب لخاشقجي ، وهذا
أمر يثير غضب العالم بأسره.
ونحن نطالب
بإجابات على ذلك ، لكنني سأشير إلى
أن كندا كانت في صراع مع
المملكة العربية السعودية على المستوى الدبلوماسي منذ
بضعة أشهر لأننا أصدرنا
بيانًا يدين اعتقال
عدد من المؤيدين للديمقراطية الموالية لأمريكا
'  منذ الصوت BIA ، سنستمر في
الدفاع عن حقوق الإنسان بحزم بينما
نبحث في نفس الوقت عن طرق لنكون
أكثر شفافية وأكثر مسؤولية
في الاقتصاد  طريقة خيارات جيم ولكن هل
هناك السيد خط.  رئيس الوزراء ، ما
الذي يتطلبه الأمر لتقول إن هذا كل شيء ، وأنا
أعلم أنه سيكلف كندا مليار
دولار لأن هذه هي العقوبة بالنسبة
لك لإلغاء اتفاقية الأسلحة هذه ، ولكن هل
هناك سطر يمكنك من خلاله الحصول على
المعلومات وأنت فقط تقول لا ، نحن لا نقوم بذلك
هذه الصفقة مع المملكة العربية
السعودية بعد الآن على الطاولة ، ونحن
مستمرون في النظر في كيفية المضي
قدمًا بشكل مسؤول ولكن أول شيء
هو الحصول على مستوى من المساءلة
والمسؤولية عن مقتل جمال
خاشقجي ثم نتخذ
قرارات بشأن  الخطوات التالية ،
لذلك قد يكون على الطاولة ، إنه
خيار تتطلع إليه لاتخاذ القرار الصحيح
بناءً على المعلومات التي
لديك في الوقت الذي لا نزال نتوقع المزيد من
المعلومات حوله